a quiet place part two proves that john  krasinski really is a master of suspense  he is almost our modern day hitchcock  but unlike the first film  there is not a lot of meat on the bone  for this  story and what doesn't really work is  that it's split up into two groups which  splits it into two story packs  one being way more interesting than the  other where the other one falls flat  doesn't feel like much is going on it  relies almost too heavily  on jump scares and suspense in this film  however  he shows a lot of progress in his  directing a lot of inspiration from  spielberg  that's with the way he shoots scenes  just like jurassic park but also having  the kids take center stage and give that  magic to it  not as good as the first film but  definitely a very worthy sequel i'm  going to give it an 8.2